laut dem Lesben und schwulenverband
identifiziert sich jede zehnte Person in
Deutschland als lgbtq+ in der Genesis
sind sogar noch mehr nämlich etwa 22
Prozent trotzdem haben sich laut Angaben
der Polizei in den Jahren zwischen 2010
und 2021 die Straftaten gegen queere
Menschen versiebenfacht die Zwiebel
Community fordert deshalb einen queren
Aktionsplan für Bayern und konkrete
Maßnahmen für mehr Gleichstellung zu
erarbeiten denn fun fact Bayern ist das
einzige deutsche Bundesland das so ein
Aktionsplan noch nicht hat was meint ihr
was sollte in so einem Aktionsplan
verankert sein um die Gleichstellung von
queren Menschen zu ermöglichen schreibt
in die Kommentare